I'm Batman with birds-of-prey doing
great at the box office these past few
days they have released a first look at
Robert Pattinson in the Batman costume I
uploaded a video the second I was done
uploading it as it was processing
notification bell oh this one is much
more relevant right now I'm Greg I'm
John let's watch this
[Music]
who the g18 escort
[Music]
oh and you been
[Music]
very metal it's very hard come night
it's got the batch in yeah it's got the
jawline
I love that music now whatever Warner
Brothers does with these test footage
first looks great marketing strategy did
it for Joker birds uh and then today to
do with that in Chapter two
and now with this one I love the bat
emblem love the red lighting now this
being a first look at the suit sort of a
test screening of the costume you know
that DC fans everywhere are gonna be
overly positive no matter what that's
the way these always go down for hey
he's got a Justice tattooed on his job
even mind this is still early stages but
you know like the Joker clown makeup
that they revealed and the tone of that
was fairly you know pretty accurate in
alignment with what we got with the
actual movie so I can imagine this is
kind of a similar case I'm curious what
stage of the suit this is at because
this is supposed to be the early years a
much younger Batman obviously so is this
the kind of suit that he put together
all by himself you know what I mean
I do like the emblem it looks functional
it looks like it might pop up and become
something about the red lighting does
sort of have this you know modern-day
film noir type of vibe to it kind of
reminded me of Batman year one too
there's that dark red cover again yeah
that's a good call and especially if
it's early Batman well speaking of red
that costume actually the mask itself
kind of looked a bit like the daredevil
mask yeah okay I'm playing it back and
especially with the red light I can see
we don't get to see what the ear shape
is we just know that he has some kind of
cape collar popping up and then what
looks like stitches on his shoulder or
something I don't know well I like that
it looks like a real cape as opposed to
the Ben Affleck one where it was a CGI
cape which they designed specifically so
he could be a little bit more noble so
he could fight better to be it looks
cool you know you can't judge a movie
off of this I feel like a lot of people
will and you I can't stop them as much
as I'll try to encourage people not to I
think from this first official glimpse
that they have publicly released I think
it looks pretty sweet
if this was
you know an actual teaser for the film
it would feel just like a really cool
YouTube short film to me I mean it's
just a shot yeah if you put this out
just on its own and called it a teaser I
think everyone would just be nonplussed
by that yeah and on the other hand I
mean I can't I would be very surprised
if people like lost their minds over
this the same way they lost their minds
over like Jared Leto's Joker look and
five or even the Larkin Phoenix one like
like this doesn't seem as upsetting
potentially to me in any way because
mostly it's just confirming that he was
gonna have a bat suit I hope we don't
see his eyes but I am hoping we do get
the white eyes in this movie the shot
will come back in the official teaser
before it cuts his eyes will blink on
maybe this is the final shot of the
movie he's just Bruce Wayne the entire
time then the final few moments he does
this yeah he does this and then he jumps
off like a you know built into the
credits I thought it looked cool what do
you guys think of the costume leave your
thoughts down below I'm excited for this
come on guys the whole cast Matt Reeves
directing this is gonna be an awesome
film I have no doubt in my mind even if
there's like three crappy trailers I
follow it I have no doubt in my mind
subscribe click that notification bell
for more you best keep a lookout for
when we got our reaction up to the
officials trailer anywho thank you guys
for being here this is a short one so
see you guys